un édifice comme des centaines d'autres
à chisinau la capitale de la moldavie
mais ce centre administratif est
particulièrement prisé ces jours ci et
là il ya plein de monde qui vient
justement de demander le passeport pour
pouvoir sortir de mon avis andrée un
jeune moldave étudiants france a lui
même décidé de renouveler ses documents
de voyage la crainte que la guerre en
ukraine déborde en moldavie le pousse à
mettre fin plus rapidement que prévu à
son séjour dans son pays natal poutine
je sais pas il peut passer peut-être de
devenir même mon avis parce que c'est ça
sera très facilement il est juste à côté
est du plus non si jamie et quelque
chose nous on n'a pas la possibilité de
les poster donc là chez nous il va
rentrer très calmement contrairement à
la plupart des pays limitrophes de
l'ukraine la moldavie ne fait ni partie
de l'otan ni de l'union européenne est
un autre facteur inquiète les autorités
du pays dans ce petit village de l'est
de la moldavie on se souvient encore de
la guerre qui a secoué le pays après
l'indépendance de l'union soviétique il
ya une trentaine d'années au début des
années 1990 victor a combattu des forces
séparatistes
appuyé par moscou
oui
nous savons ce que veut dire la guerre
lance ce vétéran qui a perdu des
camarades au combat
les images venant d'ukraine évoque
quelque chose de particulier pour lui
[Musique]
dans ce coin du pays le conflit a laissé
plus que des souvenirs yann stefani tac
qui possède un musée dans le village de
moldova thannois nous emmène jusqu'à la
frontière de la transnistrie une
république autoproclamée proche de la
russie des forces russes ils sont même
stationné depuis des décennies
une présence de l'armée russe sur ces
territoires qui se trouve tout juste à
côté de cela côté d'ici et ça c'est une
grand problème pour la moldavie soldats
moldaves et russes se trouvent donc à
proximité les uns des autres les
autorités de transnistrie assure ne pas
vouloir s'impliquer dans le conflit en
ukraine mais selon l'yonne un rien
pourrait tout faire basculer
ça peut commencer dans chaque séquence
la guérison une vulnérabilité que
reconnaissent les autorités moldaves on
est moins protégé par par des
institutions internationales
au je dirais que naît le pays le voisin
le plus fragile de l'ukraine en plus
d'enjeux liés à la sécurité le
gouvernement moldave prévient que la
guerre en ukraine aura des impacts
économiques majeures le commerce
stratégique avec le port d'odessa et
grandement touchés et les autorités
appellent à l'aide pour gérer l'arrivée
de centaines de milliers de réfugiés on
est très inquiet que si la guerre
continue
si les combats s'approche de notre
frontière ça va générer de nouvelles
vagues du réfugié ça va intensifier
cette pression sur les citoyens ne
craignant dû revenir à moldavie élan
serein dans une situation est vraiment
tragique
dans son musée rendant hommage à la vie
paysanne à quelques kilomètres du
territoire autoproclamée de transnistrie
youn stéphane ita craint aussi que le
contexte ne pose davantage de moldaves à
quitter leur pays en trente ans la
moldavie a déjà perdu un million et demi
d'habitants plus du tiers de sa
population
il y en lui assure qu'il restera malgré
les tensions émotives et dé rester et
pour être toujours là et j'espère que
l'on va passer cette page triste
des l'histoire de l'ukraine et pour la
moldavie et on doit rester toujours chez
nous et de travailler chez nous à la
maison il sera fait le bouvier auclair
radio canada mollo va thannois en
moldavie